I candle in the bathroom for your guests
so that they can poop without like
feeling self-conscious that's a great
thing today we're going to do a
blindfolded candle challenge we're gonna
try and tell the difference between
cheap and expensive candles I'm a candle
lover I don't love how expensive they
are
I love candles literally burning money
the most I've ever spent on the candle
was $40 and that was for a gift for my
mom I'm not gonna spend more than 10
bucks on a candle every candle that
smells like Mead
I can smell stuff from a mile away
usually it's pizza I think I actually
have a very very strong sense of smell I
have a sense of smell of a wolf I don't
think my nose even works Oh can't see a
thing
let's do it whoo this one's true you
know is fancy kind of exaggerated glass
shape to me that says grocery store
candle I feel like he's really cheating
here I think I might be getting high off
candles is that possible this smells
really nice yeah really I would put this
in my bathroom right it would cover up
all that nasty has to be public on
visioning like this bright bubblegum
pink in front of me right now
cheeping me expensive this could be
cheap to ion's expensive - it smells
like I mean I have my pinky up I think
this is expensive I think this one's
fancier it smells like watermelon bubble
gum but I feel like it's stronger I'm
gonna stick by my answer inside both of
these were the expensive one they both
just smelled really good I told you this
smells like I'm about to take a walk in
the park I like this one it's six months
of one can we keep the stain oh yeah I
know I want it that doesn't fancy like
friends oh I smell something
you do got a good nose that kind I think
this is the cheaper one but I like this
one I feel like the one you have right
now is the cheap candle this would be a
Beyonce handle a little lighting and
Beyonce's roommate I think that's this
the expensive one I would burn this
thing all day all day long baby I don't
know anymore
this just smells fancy I think this is
the cheap one
and I think this is the expensive one
poet no way but the thing is I like this
smell better
it's like summer breeze are one of those
made-up names this is some strong [ __ ] I
like this one better and I think this
one might be the expensive one
definitely the cheap one don't you think
the one I have yeah I agree I'm getting
some lemongrass over here wait what if
both of them are cheap oh my god I'll be
upset like hell they are they probably
are I feel like this one might be this
is like a toilet in the woods I think
both of them are cheap
Wow we're good yeah nailed it
what happened to your wolf like smelling
senses huh I could go for both I like
both of them I'm gonna go for like $20
just based on the sticker on the front I
think this is like like close to $100
isn't it like at least 80 no they're
like 40 bucks it costs $64 geha what the
hell what no way I think I did prefer
the smell of like the cheaper candles it
doesn't have to be cheap or expensive if
it smells good I think it's perfect then
you feel bad about burning your
expensive candle there are other things
you could be burning for $60 yeah it's
like when I come to your house party I'm
gonna judge you instantly how your
tattoo thank you candle exactly you know
Oprah's house it was bathroom I got
Oprah has you know those giant candles
they're like three feet oh yeah all
repairs in the toilet that's what I want
it's not time you know you've made it